comme comme comme je t'ai dis c'est pas
une guerre qui va durer au niveau du
combat brutal elle a duré au niveau de
l'humanitaire parce qu on a déjà je
crois un peu plus de six cent mille
personnes qui ont été déplacées donc ça
ça va durer les immeubles qui sont tous
détruits les villes qui sont rasés ça ça
va durer on est parti pour au moins cinq
ans
après a voir mais la partie militaire
brut excusez moi mais ça fait cinq jeux
cinq jours ça dieu ils ont pas pris kiev
alors que la partie militaire elle va
vite prendre une claque c'est ça parce
que à ce que veulent a dit m poutine je
pense qu'il avait en tête qui prennent
le kef au bout de deux trois jours et
s'armer voilà ouais voilà cinq jours on
voit que ça ce qui me fait dire que
l'armée russe prend une sévère
dérouillée sait déjà que les ukrainiens
tiennent très fort et comme je te disais
et fabrice va confirmer les missiles que
l'on voit tourner h 24 sur les images
qui n'ont pas explosé
c'est que ça veut bien dire qu'il ya
quelque chose ça veut dire quoi
s'alarmer l'armée russe est défaillante
je pense alors défaillante je pense pas
oui parce que la mission allait moins
les moyens ils ont pratiqué dans ces cas
là c'est parce que les moyens sens que
c'est vrai que dans notre dette est vrai
que l'on pensait toujours que l'armée
russe était extrêmement puissante
extrêmement bien équipé on se rend
compte alors autre hypothèse on en
parlait tous les deux est-ce que les
soldats russes ils vont à fond ou est-ce
que même les i vont à reculons et ils
n'ont ils ne veulent pas de cette
surface c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser je pense qu'ils n'en veulent pas
et journaux ils vont y voit encore un
mois recule on sait ça non ils vont pas
foncez pas une guerre qu'ils ont envie
de faire c'est une guerre qu'ils ont
porté ce n'est pas une guerre pour leur
pays en fait il dit quand on soldats
j'imagine bien quand on se dit on se bat
pour son pays on la comprend pas on là
ils la comprennent pas le choix ce
qu'ils comprennent même pas les ordres
des complets n'y a pas je suis
boursières n'ont pas je pensais sans
même dépassé par le par le gouvernement
dans le commandement et même le
commandement se retrouve dépassée par le
commandement tu vois c'est à dire qu'ils
savent même pas ce qu'ils vont ce qu'ils
vont ils faire en fait non mais ça va
pas ils vont déjà voilà des jeunes
soient vraiment pas pourquoi ils ont dit
yvon pourquoi pour amener le désarmement
et puis taper tout le monde et surtout
pas en fait donc forcément c'est ça
aussi qu'il faut c'est de faire qui fait
que ça ça capote un peu que au bout de
cinq jours on le voit la capitaine la
capitale ukrainienne est tout pas aux
vins la russie est-ce que penser qu'ils
peuvent battre en retraite ou
ses portes si votre nom je pense pas
qu'ils le feront parce que ben il faut
se rappeler armées russes ils ont connu
une bande armée sera une bien armés sur
quelque chose après quand on voit tous
et toutes ses mines tout c'est qui qui
qui n'explose pas c'est vrai que mathieu
ce que disait mathieu ça prouve bien que
il ya quand même un problème
d'équipement pour moi ça me bond qui est
un problème d'équipement un missile le
prix d'un missile qui part quand des
cinq de faire c'est ça ouais c'est il
faut qu'il fasse quelque chose c'est ça
s'il y en a quand il a réussi qui n'ont
pas explosé explique m6 et j'ai un ami
on en parlait hier il y a même atteint
il me disait tu te rends compte tous les
missiles convoi il y en a pas un qui
explose c'est vrai que c'est quand même
et quand il m'a dit ça j'ai dit tiens
elle serait que j'ai pas regardé tout de
suite mais après quand on regarde un peu
plus les images on voit le nombre de
missiles et il ya une chose qui m'a
surpris c'est un militaire ukrainien qui
a pris une grenade dans la main donc on
a des coups pieds qui a pas explosé
c'est fou je me rappelle plus trop de
mise on a fait aussi l'arrêt mais ça
tient un petit peu réduit le nombre de
fois sur la ne doit pas explosé
sergei nous a rejoint sergei quand
mathieu et fabrice parle de défaillance
de l'armée russe déjà bravo
ta vie je me faire écraser la méforme
merci sergey vous répondez quoi vous
êtes d'accord avec eux oui je suis
d'accord avec vous et d'ailleurs c'est
un autre espoir aussi parce que même
quand on menace et il me menace avec les
bombes atomiques les militaires français
et américains sont à peu près sûr que
seule la moitié et peuvent fonctionner
encore moins celle ci fait rien à moitié
mais c'est pas non mais ça veut dire
donc mais ça peut être si cette guerre
s'arrête ça peut être un énorme
camouflet pour la russie pour sa force
de persuasion une impasse que c'est vrai
que une armée ça sert surtout à ça on
dit toujours avec l'armée c'est surtout
dissuasif on s'en sert rarement la ville
a dit mercantine a voulu faire un coup
d'éclat et tous les pays se rendre
compte que la remise n'est pas au niveau
qu'on attendait sergei mais on ne sait
quand le savez la russie a perdu tout
intérieure depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale la russie a perdu l'afghanistan
lahouti a perdu je vous rappelle la
tchétchénie parce que contrairement à ce
qu'il raconte l'alchimie est là aussi a
perdu l'union soviétique a perdu les
guerres or un angola en nicaragua par
tous les américains d'ailleurs aussi le
vietnam